just us
empire building a weapon capable of
destroying an entire planet they call it
the desktop
need to capture the plans if there's any
hope of destroying it
we want to help alright how many do I
need i'll be there for you
the captain said I had to tell me that
we are dealing with here is immeasurable
sale
the Imperial forces are converging on a
present location
take hold of this moment
the force is strong
tell me you have a back-up plan
content
the force be with us
one a star war story
you almost got me know welcome ready
pg-13
hey youtubers it's Charlie new road one
footage so let's break it down
there's also a whole bunch of Jedi stuff
in here that we haven't talked about in
previous trailers so the trailer is all
about trusting each other trusting the
force but the force part of that is a
much bigger deal and we actually see Jim
with like a little crystal around her
neck the Kyber crystals were actually
being mined from the special Jedi planet
there are two big locations that we've
seen in all these trailers aside from
the actual interior of the Death Star
there's the tropical planet which is
scarf which is actually where the Death
Star's being built then there's the
planet where they're mining the Kyber
crystals from which is called Jed haha
it's actually a term that's taken from
some of Lucas's original work in
original word for the Jedi it was
something that was created for this
movie like it didn't exist in the star
wars universe before they wrote the
story for Star Wars wrote one but it's
meant to be this special moon that's
kind of like a holy place like Jerusalem
or Mecca that Jedi would go on
pilgrimages to there's a holy city there
that we see in this trailer that's like
a very sacred city but they're Kyber
crystals there so during the fall of the
old republic in the rise of the Empire
they started to use it to mine for
crystals to create the Death Star
superlaser see this really WTF
desecration of this galactic holy site
so for those of you wondering this
wasn't something that showed up in the
original Star Wars films or even the
prequels this is something they're
weaving into the mythology but there
were always places that the Jedi would
go to search for force crystals to make
their lightsabers
so one of the most fun things for me
when I go see this movie is going to be
trying to pick out the new bits of
mythology they try to weave in there
will also be present in the new saga
films like in the way during episode 7
Luke Skywalker had gone on a pilgrimage
to try and find the original jedi temple
we see a whole bunch more k2s oh I can
already sense he's going to be one of my
favorite new characters so hopefully if
he doesn't get blown to smithereens show
up in the new films too but that's
another thing to their been talk that
they're not going to do saga films
anymore after episode 9 but they'll
still be doing Star Wars movies it's
just that when they said that they might
not do saga films anymore they were
talking about trilogies especially ones
that follow the Skywalker family so you
guys can let me know
you think about that because if they did
do that then they would do more films
like this just a really big story from
the star wars universe but a relatively
self-contained one but they all would
still be in the same continuity so you
might see characters from one movie pop
up in another but it wouldn't
necessarily be like a beginning middle
and through three films it would just be
like this continuing story is they jump
around the galaxy and jump around in the
timeline but personally i would really
like to see them try to go back into the
past at least once for like an old
republic movie like the Knights of the
Old Republic movie would be so badass
after episode 9 because you can still do
a lot of the same really awesome things
that you do in Star Wars films but with
completely different characters in a
time in a setting that we've never
really seen before in the Star Wars
movies but i know this is like the trust
trailer so on the flip side is so funny
to see krenek asking for Darth Vader's
trust in if you've seen episode for you
know that Darth Vader was not impressed
with the Death Star
he's like this is nothing compared to
the power of the force
so we might see a version of that
conversation in the movie where he tries
to appeal to Vader invader just
completely shuts them down but because
of the weird position that Vader holds
inside the Empire he's kind of off on
his own he oversees things but he's also
in charge of destroying the rebellion so
most of his interest in this story is in
tracking down the rebels he probably
barely cares about the construction of
the death star like the only other big
story that i would really like to see
out of him in this is him at this Jedi
holy place on the jet ha planet because
he would have an interest in their
mining Kyber crystals even if he wants
to crush the Jedi Order he still
respects the force like he still has a
reverence for it so he may be horrified
that they're trying to destroy this
special Jedi plays hopefully they don't
blow it up when they test that super
laser but i think this is going to be a
lot of fun i'm mostly interested in how
they made this just as much as I am in
the actual story itself and they did
post like a behind-the-scenes featurette
so if you haven't seen it here it is
right here
but nine since I was four hours gonna be
shooting star wars film would have
planned it all my life
this film is character's story I grew up
with it's a whole world have been
thinking about for quite a long time you
can feel everyone in the career in the
classroom stops and just take that in
and you remember actually install ward
it's like the world's greatest joy said
it's a bit like being a kid again the
star wars figures
stormtroopers over here in this happens
explosion it's been a lot of fun
it's the greatest job in the world
broken and takes place very close to
episode 4
the simplest way to explain it is that
text you see at the beginning of a new
hope
that is essentially anything
they call it the desktop terrible weapon
has a way to defeating James starting to
put together a team wants to fight we
all do our many doing it it isn't
ensemble movie but at the heart there's
a strong the time to fight is now every
day they grow stronger
all these characters are real heroes
that are willing to risk everything like
the place huh make them feel like a
hundred through their journey we see the
formation of the Rebel Alliance and
stealing the desktop times you are not
willing to risk being behind
a chance to speak up that is a bad idea
they achieve what they achieved because
they achieve it together
she's wrong
I know the droid is going to be a lot of
fun in this but watching donnie yen in
all these clips just gets me super hype
about badass ninja jedi skillz he's
blind in the movie and he's technically
not a Jedi but he's basically the ob one
of the group the mystic who trust in the
force whereas at least at the beginning
of the movie everyone else is on the
fence about it you know more like Han
Solo at the beginning of episode 4 cut 2
episode 7 and he is a full-on believer
in the power of the force
so Donnie Yen is going to be amazing in
this and let's not forget about mass
Mickelson who just showed up in Doctor
Strange this character i think it's
going to be a little more fully formed
his doctor strange character was really
cool that it fell prey to the common
problem in big superhero movies with
underdeveloped villains
the character he's playing on this is
someone who is presented with the
impossible situation save his family by
having to work for the Empire so he has
to help build the death star which is
this terrible weapon of mass destruction
but if he doesn't his family will die
so even though his doctor strange
character was really cool I think he's
going to be much cooler in wrote one so
what's going to happen when the movie
gets here I'll do my review video like I
would normally do all to easter eggs in
stuff for episode 8 if there are any
special star wars bonus videos you guys
want me to start doing just let me know
in the comments so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and if you're looking
for a really good story to read to get
ready for Road one that's part of the
cannon catalyst is the new novel they
just release it is a rogue one prequel
so it's not like crazy-big not a huge
time investment but if you want to read
classic comics to get into the history
of the Jedi just really big deep cuts
and recommend Golden Age of this city or
tails of the Jedi Dark Lords of the Sith
the Sith war technically they're not
canon anymore but there's still like
really awesome stories about Jedi
history Jedi and Sith history
specifically tomorrow is going to be
walking dead game of thrones and then
West world will be on monday so get
height is gonna be awesome
while you guys wait for the post you can
click here for my captain marvel most
powerful character video you can click
here for that flash arrow extended
trailer
thank you so much watching everybody
that bottle see you guys tonight
mini-me mini-me anything